senator you have brought a friend Thank
You mr. Attorney General for being here
you know the news broke just moments ago
that you will testify before the House
Judiciary Committee next month so we are
honored that you would sit down with us
first and very much appreciate it I want
to get right into this obviously there's
so much going on and it occurs to me we
have a man who writes the laws we have
the man who enforces the laws and we
have popular calls for utter lawlessness
in the country how do we restore order
well it's going to it's going to take
both state and local government as well
as federal government the federal
government is best positioned to address
this kind of violence and lawlessness
after it occurs because we don't have
FBI agents walking the beat and in fact
when when the real violence started
around May 25th 6th and so forth we
started using our joint terrorist task
forces around the country and there 35
of them around the country it involves
all state and local in those
jurisdictions and all the federal
agencies and it's the system we designed
to follow terrorists and now they are
starting to go full-bore cranking out
investigations indictments against the
people who are involved in this violence
so if we've had scores of indictments
already for such things as arson
destruction of federal property things
like that and we have right now about
500 investigations underway so it's
picking up pace and we are committed to
holding accountable the people who are
engaged in this but we still have to try
to stop it before it happens and that's
where the burden is right now on state
and local and in many places they're not
stepping up to the plate there they're
not doing their job so I know it's early
but but how much indications are y'all
saying of coordination and planning
rather than spontaneous acts of violence
right we are we are seeing a strong
evidence of coordination and many of
these violent episodes fundamentally
what you have here is you have
demonstrators some of them go there with
the intent of demonstrating
you have a group of provocateurs and
agitators sometimes a significant group
they try to convert those into violent
activity and they seem to be very well
coordinated when they show up a number
of Myr sociated with the movement called
gente but they go by various names but
frequently an artistic they want to tear
down the country the there different
than many traditional groups and
frequently the signs of coordination and
activity are very close to the event
itself like the morning of or the day
before and things are very fast-moving
but we definitely see signs out on the
street of communication of organization
of pre-planning pre positioning of
things so it's definitely organized a
well if if you're calling in the
Terrorism Task Force
that means presumably that we're dealing
with terrorism here I know the president
came out and said just a couple of days
ago that this will not be tolerated on
federal land you cannot destroy federal
property and he's authorizing the
government to go and hold people
accountable what will this mean in terms
of a change of policy or an acceleration
of a policy that was already in place
well it's not it's not a change in
policy in the sense that we've always
had the obligation as the federal
government to protect federal facilities
and federal landmarks and monuments and
so forth but now because in some places
the local police are not doing an
adequate job we're going to have to step
up the federal effort to do that and so
that there are two aspects to it
obviously we're going to prosecute right
now all the videos involved in the
attack on the president Jackson's
statute are being carefully reviewed and
we will go after people so if you attack
a monument on federal property you're
gonna get prosecuted that's right yeah
but we're also being and and the the
criminal statute has serious jail time I
mean oh that's a 10 years 10 years
yep and the other thing is we have to do
a better job of trying to stop these
groups when they before they are 8
to do damage to these monuments instead
it's fine to punish them afterward but I
think a lot of us would like the statues
to remain up